after maintaining a low profile
following a very public defamation trial
against her ex-husband Johnny Depp last
year Amber Heard is now re-emerging on
screen
but I'll travel to the edge of the world
to prove myself
fail the 37 year old actress appears in
the new period drama in the fire which
recently premiered at the tormina film
festival and she's set to star in the
upcoming DC sequel Aquaman and the lost
kingdom
this was orange doing
the worst is yet to come speaking with
deadline hurt explains the pressure she
feels being in a big budget film
explaining
there's a ton of pressure on these big
franchise movies with millions and
millions of dollars at stake and
compromises are part of trying to make
it the most successful thing it can be
adding then on the other end of the
spectrum is a small indie film like in
the fire a work of art and a work of
love with nowhere near the same
resources and so there are compromises
there despite balancing both projects at
once the actress says she is grateful
for the opportunities sharing Aquaman
that franchise and the Machinery behind
it I'm very honored honored to be part
of that and then there are these small
passion projects like in the fire where
I'm proud to have gotten to know the
filmmaker and the cast and we got dirty
together to breathe life into this story
there's something cool about that